of course we do need to play basic sound
clips for grits though we have robots
moving around the 2d world making noise
and causing mayhem it doesn't make a lot
of sense for a sound on the opposite
side of the game map from the player to
be just as loud as the one right next to
them so it's not quite enough for a game
like grits what we need is to also add
the ability to adjust the volume based
on the game state and that solves the
problem I just mentioned with Web Audio
we can adjust the volume of sounds based
on how far they are from a player's
position on the screen this provides a
much more realistic sound environment
than you could achieve with for example
the audio element you can think of a lot
more situations where it could be cool
to have more involved sound effects
maybe you want to apply an echo effect
based on how sound reflects off flat
walls or apply a Doppler effect based on
the velocity of a player or a projectile
this can quickly get pretty involved in
grits we simplify this and go for basic
volume changes the point is you need to
think about what level of sound
complexity is right for your game and
your team